welcome to this video 15 minute game
against hi Neeka Heineken yeah from
Germany I haven't played him before so
this drew a blank the statistics
okay I've played a Slav he went from
early g3 and young g3 yeah that's it
it's a slightly risky move because white
can white has problems to get the pawn
back if I take on c4 and it's not the
Catalan I have yet they have not yet
played e6 mm-hm this is one way to go
the other is to just develop okay I'm
taking taking this but I'm always a bit
skeptical about those type of porn grabs
let's see one additional possibility is
to avoid p6 all together and play g6
going from star but okay I guess I need
to provide some cover for the porn
anyway okay
you know 97 yeah it's it's really very
non very similar to the Catalan if he
goes Eve for now he doesn't the question
is if I take it play 95 is he going to
play six maybe this type of sacrifice
can be a big big problem okay what what
else I can also try to just ignore the
threat on the C pawn if I take take 95
mm yeah I don't like him if you play c6
this I don't like so much one way to
play in this type of position is a six
giving up on the c6 pawn so knight c6
Queen b6 winning a tempo okay the point
is after 96 Queen b6 if he just returns
to e5 I can exchange the important
bishop and this should lead to a very
very decent game for black but I'm not
sure about is if he takes Queen b6 and
then maybe d5 but I can take easy 65 95
thus I overlooked really okay I better
wake up here and it's immediately really
really bad because he falls of course
exceptionally weak
hmm oh man Wow and took me some time to
blunder this
if I take it this would be seven is
there some way to know don't really have
a move after that
wow that's really bad yeah what what the
heck did I do them don't even see a move
that's that's halfway playable takes
takes Queen b6 blah maybe okay yeah this
will be tough even though against a very
low rated player this position as some
that's really really dreadful just
terribly bad structure okay
check
yeah hey this is also good for white no
doubt if I go see five now can I at
least exchange the light squared bishop
he has got this check my dissing never
this has at least some kind of defense
okay I need to do it anyway
if I'm if I give him even more time and
then it becomes worse and worse okay he
can go Queen a for Quincy forward
probably I cannot I couldn't keep the
material anyway in the six maybe I can
get to the six if he is not careful
enough check
yeah the easiest is to take and take C
form what takes c4 first everything I
can take here here I should should take
on you should take first on b7 just take
b7 and takes e4 that's the easiest yeah
maybe you have some more powerful move
like that it's not it's not possible I
don't see I don't see one though this is
simple and good okay
okay if I Castle I cannot I cannot be
with the bishop at the moment because of
beat winging the wood I will take it
yeah
don't know if there's a move more
precise than castles
maybe there is I don't know but I need
to need to not fall too far behind on
the clock
yeah he wants to go to his 7 to support
the pawn and this is an idea but I can
take here right what exactly is the
point of this rook be one and look to
look to be seven probably
yeah that's not bad at all and something
I probably should avoid okay if he gets
to e7 I don't mind that to watch its ass
Bishop okay it covers d6 but other than
that it's doing not much okay
yeah it's not much fun
groveling with just being a pawn down
mmm YUM of course the only way to to
defend the successful is if you make
some kind of mistake
not it's not like I can do much on my
own I would really like him to play
Bishop e7 this would be helpful so that
this Bishop is not attacking potentially
the c5 pawn
what I can try to do is a form get rid
of one weakness and maybe get player
against the b3 bone but it's not yeah
it's nothing to write home about
Wow
that's a very surprising move this would
have been very very low on my list of
candidate moves probably I don't know
most the least likely moves who what
does he do for a five-year before five
but I have any finds right okay okay I'm
going to attack the d6 pawn and get look
before into the into the game it's a
possible way to get more activity okay
so look before and possibly a for the
bishop only seven is really not doing
much
protecting the pawn of course but other
than that it's not especially great the
question is where is he going maybe to
c3 I can try I can try to to block block
before even with the move f5 if we can
see six of course but yeah f5 I'm going
to play e5 f6 and this is maybe
dangerous
yeah I'm re f5s as possible
I don't like Roxy for against that I
want to play a foursome to get rid of
the a pawn and maybe get something
against the b3 pawn but he will play a 5
there's no no question maybe I can play
rocky 4 against that okay I don't know I
need to need to play a movement at some
point
falling far behind on the clock would be
even worse this was the point
getting the Queen's off okay I can take
here first so that Queen c6 is not
really possible
it gives up the b3 pawn and they don't
think he wants that
so we place a beef and then yeah after
the Queen trade he's giving up the pole
that's surprising maybe he gets a quick
look here okay a seven and combined rook
aah yeah that's it's indeed possible
okay
yeah the rook on the seventh would be
especially fatal yeah okay I see your
point I probably cannot take on b3
because of uk1 I need to get some room
for the King King f7 the b3 part is big
anyway I mean if he we must cover it
with stuff like rooks III and rook f3
then something like this then the worst
is is over anyway
okay there's also now possibly Knight f6
to reform but okay only only on a very
good day I'm managing that how came
yeah it's not apparent how white white
should win this but how however I am
going to do anything it's even less
apparent I probably should play look a 6
a 2 B to get this rook involved within
White's camp this is probably better I
have very little active possibilities
you 65 but ok yeah ok that's that
supporting the D pawn so I cannot easily
move the the night I wonder if he was
just crazy him okay I briefly thought
Brooks he fire pertussis indeed don't
completely crazy okay so I have the a
file and have the second rank so maybe
there is something I can do
rookie form would to check the to pawn
but you always have has rookie three
there maybe if he plays somewhat
somewhat key are smooth like King f3
here it is I can play e5 and use this
this some use the the fork if I have
takes Knight if I've check maybe but I
also must because I'm not there enough
mated can easily happen there in an
admitted that the D pawn I can try to
meet him but that the D pawn is suddenly
getting getting
unstoppable but at the end I have
rocketed from know I can do that takes
night X check King whatever takes rook
takes rook g-form
and I'm I'm stopping it yeah
check and there's also there are also
some possibilities to to play for
checkmate
this is also something to calculate
let's say here this rook here
rookie - that's not not bad at all
threatening to meet him and what is he
doing against it really III is not
playable rookie 3 runs into Knight g4
threatens rook rook a to e to check King
on the first row
check group here check and it's made you
can go to to h3 but then that's not g4
with mate I think it was very dangerous
and if I should have miscalculated I
cannot state the d7 pawn if he goes d7
but I think it's really it really is a
mate
on the first check King honking look it
will check King age 394 King King age
from Luke age to check King g5 not sure
that hasn't made I can play rook h2 mmm
but I don't see a mate yet okay like
evidence I can always take the seven but
that's of course not what I wanted
look a tree to check King g1 check on
ebon okay so I'm going to go right here
no sounds nothing better
and now okay is there some point in
first taking here I don't think so yeah
okay keep it to keep it simple
this was my original intention and it
should win now getting the b-pawn
very very tough call g6 no King e6
probably ya don't want to give up at
five really I can always take it toward
or b3 there's no need to rush and here
yeah on this seven I can can take the
bishop which is important so no King g7
Bishop c5 I don't want to play with just
with an exchange up so what now on the C
pawn you know I can I can just let this
let this bond advance yeah that was a
very very critical position I'm not so
sure about this
endgame really nice design the endgame
wasn't easy of course I was in big
trouble
after a blunder tonight b5 but around
Shiites is just dreadful yeah 93 is also
possible of course this is a disaster I
simply simply overlooked Knight takes d5
there's if I don't do that there is
nothing special happening here it's just
an interesting position I should
probably play something like that to
come with the bishop yeah this is just a
disaster
absolute disaster okay
93 is probably even better but this is
here I really would have considered to
take with not this fake take with the
Queen also interesting you have this
retreat square
now white is white is better in
basically every line I mean there's no
question that this is also better for
white but I think there were worse
positions now the the point is located
and it's not not so clear-cut how he
wins and I don't really I don't like
this this F for business is not really
to the point I mean you can play just
technically pile up on the C pawn for
example not really Bishop e7 is not
helping with that and now we went there
and here I mean it's probably still good
for white but I have gained a bit a bit
of activity you know right here this is
here it's important I mean you must be
cautious if I take b3r okay one is
probably probably killing me with rook
e8 or look p7 it is really really bad
so I wanted to get some some room for
the king and this is a very passive
approach maybe you should play that
and here yeah I'm hanging on I mean I
have made some progress I'm still worth
but yeah I was just trying to keep the
game going okay some activity and this
is runs in twenty five simply and he had
the computers for the first time in this
game giving an equal evaluation yeah it
wants to play wiki three allowi form
check yeah okay yeah but here here I'm
at the point where I'm probably not
worth any more I mean this is just a big
porn and it's not doing much and I have
active pieces they are all active
computers on equal here it's not so easy
to play this as white I mean you cannot
move the rocks and Brooks much okay yeah
if you shouldn't allow e-file of course
and I can just do something else like a
slow strengthening move but it's already
not so not so easy for white to make any
progress
he allowed too much activity yeah and
after after the captures it's basically
gone
rookie four is stronger than taking on
d3 and on d7 I was trying to figure out
the weight and this is the mate
surprising I came because this is not
avoidable okay
check check check
yeah there are many many mates yeah so
he didn't really have a move here like
his winning this check check was one of
the of the winning continuations yeah
this is what's lucky against after this
this brain slip in the opening keep
giving away b5 just this is just crazy
but somehow I fought myself back into it
and he went into this this king of 3d5
business okay thanks for watching